Nói tên đi ra bói, người này chưa được mới đi ra.
Hôm nay giờ mới biết là đến khá,
hay cũng để làm cũng kể công,
cũng đã được mấy ngày hôm được ảo,
nó không xói.
Đấy lâu rồi, đã có nhiều người nữa.
Mình đi làm cái chập đụng.
Còn có vẻ chí dưới,
mấy cũng nên đã tới tầm khoảng,
giữa tầm sau thì sẽ hợp lý tầy thường thường.
Đà số 1 người về buôi thì hôm nay,
tói này là 1 người mới lần,
là nên rồi chí vòi có lươi ,
... cũng là rất là búb đến khi hay vẻ chmand
để giận người hay phát hiệnh là chiếm dưỡng,
nhưng mà giờ là chiếm mình chiếm bà
thì cũng có lần thầy dân.
Mài đến tháng này thì cũng là thầy dân hình,
Thái dài cũng không thầy để lòng hôm được,
và thì cái thứ ngọt dưỡng và cái bé đẹp.
Vậy không wz thầy dân ngãn ơi,
của ngọc
có cái ngọc khoảng,